the jurogan experience well he's a
criminal democratic
trump he's a criminal yeah who's not
funny um and should be in jail
um but how about that huh i mean he's
threatened he's calling and threatening
people
telling them not to journalists yeah
calling and threatening people he's
calling other people going hey man
politicians you know we're
you know we don't we we act a certain
way i don't know what the quote is jamie
you'll find it but he said something to
the guy like mafia
yeah well the the hill army um uh
crystal and sagar covered it today
on their uh their show and it's uh on
there's a clip
on their instagram page uh showing the
the guy
and he's explaining what they said and
what cuomo said to him
but he basically said i will destroy you
yeah which is like
they they were lively they said nice
yeah they said
accurately this is cartoonish yeah it's
cartoon and they all get caught the same
thing with ted cruz on a plane or this
guy doing that like you all get caught
it's no longer like the 60s
when they could just with impunity do
whatever they wanted well he's a 70 year
old guy he's probably been doing this
his whole life of course he has but like
you get caught now and then they look
terrible yeah when they get caught well
that's the least of it
yeah he looks terrible the reason why he
doesn't want them to say things yeah
is because they lied about the covid
numbers in nursing homes
the cova deaths in nursing homes which
are directly
attributable to his policies killed
crazy literally they lied about 50
percent
wow they they lied at a 50 right so
yeah whatever the [ __ ] the number was it
was 50
off the real number wow which is
thousands
of deaths so it was a brush thousands
thousands of people
died that died just think of a pile
think of like a show that you and i
would do at a nice theater
sure i think of those people just
stacked up dead yeah because of the
decision of a politician can they get
right
is it is is it uh is it a because i know
that they're trying to recall newsome
they're trying to recall him too they're
trying to they're gathering
the momentum to try to recall him right
now but on top of that there's also
i don't know if this is true but i was
reading about the potential
fbi investigation there's a criminal
investigation well there should be yeah
well his one of his aides leaked the
fact that they were worried
that these numbers were going to get out
and that it was going to help the trump
administration so they
yeah this is all crazy it's all crazy
but also i'm a [ __ ]
i don't really know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about let's just be really clear
i'm listening to people like crystal and
sagar that are from the hill from rising
i actually know what they're talking
about
and i'm reiterating what they're yeah
just just say to that well i know what
i'm talking about and cuomo should go to
jail
here it is u.s attorney fbi
investigating cuomo's handling of
nursing home deals okay now
though this is on nbc whenever something
gets on
nbc you know they're [ __ ] right
because this is a democrat
right when they're covering this on nbc
they're throwing them on the bus not
only that
they've also barred his brother from
ever interviewing him
on cnn well yeah that's i mean that's a
dog and pony show the idea that he could
even
interview his own brother and toss him
softball questions but jake tapper
wants to interview him i believe is jake
tapper i think who's a credible
journalist right and they're like uh-uh
he doesn't want to talk to jake tapper
because jake tapper is going to hold his
feet to the fire or whoever it is
remember in the beginning cuomo was the
star
yes like chelsea handler's like i want
to [ __ ] cuomo like they were all
he was a star she said that it wasn't
being him she said yeah
that's your reward that's a threat uh
but the how would she do it too
she'd be on top yeah and she'd punch him
yeah as soon as she came she'd punch him
right in the nose
he was the star everybody loved him in
the beginning and they were like he's
handling it brilliantly
i thought so i thought so this is what i
thought
i thought he he's calm and he looks like
a leader
i mean this is like you know you see a
man who was handling things in a very
calm
manner and but as time went on he
started to crack
right yeah you see this with people that
respond to pressure and criticism
it changes their character this is what
i was talking about with my friend
right this brilliant guy who's dealing
with uh social media pressure
that just you take in too much criticism
it starts to change your perspective
which starts to change your behavior
which becomes ultimately very
detrimental
and you see it with cuomo when he starts
saying one of the things that he said
about like lockdowns he's like
you know if you didn't want to gain
weight you shouldn't hate the cheesecake
right you didn't listen you didn't
listen you didn't wear your mask you
didn't social distance
that's not what it is you [ __ ] idiot
right that's not what it is
what it is is this virus is very
complicated and it's confusing because
it was made in a goddamn lab probably
again i'm a [ __ ] but yeah people that i
know that are smart think it was made in
a lab right and they think that what
happens is when you enforce lockdowns
you force people inside
and you force people to be right on top
of each other and they breathe each
other's air and that's how people get
sick
right and it's more likely that they're
going to get sick that way than if you
let them
do things and just [ __ ] go out in
public and just yeah
go around and go places and make well
this was also a guy that when new york
was descending into a
crime infested hellscape he said i'll
everybody come back i'll cook for you
i'll cook food i'll
there's people in new york right now
beating each other with metal bats in
the streets
to death and de blasio has people doing
a dance routine
at cuomo's town people he'll make them
sunday sauce it's a little
how about it's a little disturbing video
i sent you that right yeah it's absurd
how about how
it's crazy it's one of the crazy ones i
post on twitter
yeah rare times i post on twitter i
posted that and i said
how the [ __ ] is this how is this real
how's this real thing yeah it's
literally a coen brothers sketch it's a
it's a scene in the big lebowski
yeah absurdist beyond belief yeah
please play that yeah he has a dance
we're gonna bring back culture
we're gonna bring back the arts this is
what you say when you've never created a
business yeah
this is the kind of [ __ ] that you do and
they're not even good at this play this
they're horrible no but it's not just
they're horrible
they're part of and we're going to do
that we're going to really bring back
the heart and soul new york city we need
our arts and culture back and we need
people to see it and feel it to
participate in it to know that that
essence of new york city has not been
defeated
by the coronavirus but will come back
strong in twice
what is his that is 2021 as you see the
city come back to life
culture will lead the way open culture
is another step towards a recovery for
our city stop
launching with stop stop stop stop i
can't
this if i was a businessman who lost
their business
because they wouldn't allow me to stay
open but they allowed target to be open
they allow these giant where was the guy
with the bat for that
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience